Il est temps que les travailleurs précaires puissent
vivre de leur salaire.
Il faut en finir avec les fins de mois le 15, hein,
si c'est pas avant
se demander comment on va payer les factures,
comment on va payer les gardes d'enfants.
Dernièrement, on a eu euh. La prime ppv,
euh la prime pouvoir d'achat que Macron a instauré, euh.
Juste après le Covid.
Et en fait, euh. Cette prime ppv,
donc on l'aperçoit,
elle est pas imposée par le patron, hein.
Donc euh. Tout va bien pour le patron.
Et nous, quand on la touche cette prime ppv ?
Euh, si on touche la,
si on gagne la prime d'activité
en plus de notre salaire,
euh. On nous retire la prime d'activité,
donc finalement, on y gagne rien.
Et il est temps que. Euh.
Que les salaires, ils soient indexés sur l'inflation.